hi guys and welcome back to city
skylines now in this episode I've
actually recorded using OBS and so far I
haven't really seen any real difference
in quality but it does seem that OBS was
a lot more laggy and I hope that's not
going to show in the time match because
even though it's recorded at eight times
the speed right now it might actually
still be like it so far it seems to be
okay so I'm happy about that and yeah
the reason I had to do that was because
my computer right now is completely
riddled with fraps files and they're
huge and I've got so many videos of this
game and so much stuff that I still need
to come out and that also poses a
problem which is something that I've
already encountered in some of my videos
of this series it's the fact that the
synchronization between the creator and
the audience over here is not really the
thing that it should be because as soon
as something goes wrong in one of my
episodes for example you have that one
highway which I think I still didn't
change the direction of so it's still
crappy highway at this point is
something that I did change and right
now as I'm saying this I think I changed
it a couple of days ago but on the last
video that I uploaded it wasn't even
changed yet and that is a problem
because I've been playing city skylines
pretty much 24 7 right now that is as
long as I'm not sleep sleeping or having
test week but yeah the issue with that
is of course is I'm playing this more
than I can upload videos of it and that
means that there are some
synchronization troubles with this but
you know it's not too big of an issue
and I still gladly make these timelapses
because I still think that it's a bit
better at least in my opinion than just
a real-life gameplay real time I mean
with the hell and for the main reasons
that if you do it real time line you're
gonna have those problems where somebody
builds a hydro dam I'm just naming a
random thing that could happen i'm not
saying this happened to every single
let's play on youtube ever but imagine
that I build a hydro dam and it takes me
10 minutes and ten minutes of
excruciating pain and torture of me
placing that damn and sucking at it and
actually drowning all of my people my
city then it
wouldn't be 10 minutes of excruciating
pain and torture but a little over 1
minute and that's that's a lot better I
suppose and then there is the thing that
you know I just like to play this game
or for creating the city than the
gameplay itself so i think the videos
also also should be more about the
progress and the city then me playing
this game and i might actually do some
real time stuff in the near future
probably in a couple of days because so
far i've only had time lapse is really
no real time to show off the city and
explain what everything is now this
little area that I'm working on right
now is something I also haven't
explained yet i decided that i would
have some forest industry because i
don't it just looked it just looked cool
that was really the only reason i wanted
to do that and the look of my city is
very important to me so i wanted to try
that forest industry and the reason i
placed all those trees before I place
the industry is because I thought that
you wouldn't be able to actually place
the industry if you don't have any trees
over there but it seemed like it still
places the forest industry even if you
don't have too much forest so but i'm
not entirely sure about Matt bow and
then I was like yeah I might as well add
a little neighborhood next to that
pretty cute I do like this area and the
only problem that I do have with that
was as you can see the highway is
extremely complicated at this point just
like most of my higher ways because I
didn't have that T Junction over there
and then I suddenly wanted to change it
into a for highway interchange and then
it turned into this mess it's working
all right but it's one big ramp fest so
I'm not going to change that though
because I do kind of like that in that
respect but it is not really the most
beautiful thing ever or the most
realistic thing or the most cheeping
because shouldn't forget that these
ramps aren't really cheap still cost me
a lot of money to have all these
highways with complicated ramp stuff and
it's kind of funny how the people in the
city actually know exactly which ramps
to take and where they should go on my
highways because they're so incredibly
complicated even without the signs I
would feel like any normal person would
incredibly lost on my highways which I
would understand and at this point i
took this area again and I was like okay
we had enough of this this stuff in my
River I don't wanna have all these weird
windmills in my River I'm gonna use
different green energy i'm just gonna
install the solar power plant which
actually saves me a lot of money too so
at this point i am earning a [ __ ] loads
of money and one thing that you can see
though is that the industrial demand is
extremely high and yeah that's also a
time compression out arrow over here
because yeah at this point i didn't even
realize that offers stones were actually
industrial zones i I thought for a very
long time that office was commercial now
it doesn't really seem to make too much
sense if you look at the layout and see
it next to the industrial zone but I was
like I completely had the same city
mindset and I almost feel like SimCity
mindset is the one big pit all for this
game because it is not SimCity but
anyway I was like hey I have my industry
I have my university why is this
industry not turning into the more
educated kind of industry all that
high-tech and industry that's what I
wanted in this case but I didn't get
that for their main reason that
high-tech industry in this game kind of
is the office zone and actually heard
some things about that you are able to
get good industry if you actually raise
the land value of the industry zones
with parks and stuff like that but I
want to avoid parks at all costs even
though I love them and I'm so conflicted
about this I do want to keep the the
what's it called again the density
thingy for commercial zoning the demand
that's the word yeah now that's what I
want to keep high and for some reason
due to some bug the diamond seems to
drop when you play sports so I went to
put this and at that point i installed
the cargo station
the traffic was completely destroyed by
this thing like that were trucks flying
in and out of this building in very
weird and glitchy ways and suddenly this
entire area was so crowded that I had to
install a highway over here and then
place that thing again but even then
that didn't work and I was just like
yeah whatever this this cargo thing
doesn't really seem to work so at some
point I am actually going to rebuild the
cargo train station over there I'm going
to reserve that spot for another train
station but I'm only going to open that
as soon as i get an outside connection
so i can actually use that thing for
well doing stuff with the outside and
then i can build an office zone around
that have the cargo train station supply
my office zones with industrial goods
from other cities because i want to get
rid of all the industry that I can in my
city because i don't like industry and
here is all the cars flying into the
cargo station it's ridiculous how much
that was like nope that's not going to
happen I'm going to remove that and this
is going to be an industrial area with
my weird kind of roundabout road section
over here because that was really not a
lot of space over here and then I had to
install a ramp to the other side and
that was also kind of complicated and
yeah I don't really know this is the
best idea for a section like this but I
was just like damn i need to i have
industrial demand that i need to place
industry and i did not realize that
office songs would actually well get rid
of all that email for an industry and i
suppose that it is an issue with time
I've said you could I I am sure this is
a very relatable thing but you know that
sometimes you're just watching these
Let's Plays and the person who's let's
playing the game is sucking at something
in the game or the game in general it
was like no you need to do this and this
but you can't tell them of course and
you just like sit sitting there in front
of your screen going yeah you need to do
that but you can't do that because he
doesn't hear you and you start pace
moming yourself and that isn't effects
I'm having with myself right now my my
past self doing all these stupid things
of course he's not doing only stupid
things but some stupid things I mean the
office thingy is not all that great but
then again i do like these areas I mean
the future silver red was pretty darn
good at making these residential areas
with parks and such at this point i was
actually building parks here you can you
can see that this was still the face of
the game where I didn't realize that
parks would actually drop my commercial
demand and you can see that I have
absolutely zero commercial demand
despite having only a couple of
commercial zones in my city so that
wasn't all that fortunate ever I still
do like the look of this area so i
suppose that that's more important than
the well-being of my citizens i mean the
the most important thing is that city
should look good in my eyes at least in
this game at least I suppose and here
comes my stupid naming of cities again
i'm pretty sure i caught those cities
hong kong and singapore beautiful cities
in real life though tight I was like
okay this is a new this is a nice new
area i'm going to name that often my
cities but yeah anyway that's it for
this episode so thank you for watching
and I'll see you on the next episode and
the next episode will be the episode in
which I remove all of my parks get tons
of demand for commercial zones and start
redoing the entire downtown area so
that's going to be great so I'll see you
then